hallo ihr lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen motto und zwar
von dem motto ob amputation und december
menton mod und zwar dieser masche für
die 1 punkt 4.5 draußen requires motto
oder als man worte für den modder und ja
also was macht dieser mod eigentlich und
zwar dieser mod macht etwas ganz simples
und zwar wenn ihr einen nennen ein
monster vor ich habt und ihr das ganz
einfach schlag entfallen seine sachen
nach herunter und es blutet also das als
ein ganz ganz ganz ganz simple motto der
letzte auch simpel zu installieren und
auch simple anzuwenden und macht auch
simple sachen was der hier macht das was
ich hier irgendwie acht der zombie wird
angestellt von dem typen oder solcher
nicht höher
na egal ich versuche ich das mal
trotzdem zu zeigen und zwar wenn ich zum
beispiel ich nehme das plätze erst wenn
ich das einmal schlage zweimal schlagen
wenn ich das jetzt ein drittes mal
schlag da ist natürlich tod und gucke
mal was dann passiert ist bericht in
seine einzelteile und diese einzelteile
die kann ich auch noch ein bisschen hin
und her schieben
das ist ganz witzig und nachher zeit
verschwinden ich weiß nicht ob es jetzt
bei den hier auch geht jetzt fällt auch
in seine einzelteile und zwar seht ihr
der blut wird auch noch das ist nämlich
der zombie die sache kann jetzt auch
hinterher schieben also ein bisschen
realistischer und das blut bleibt auf
jeden fall erstmal im zeit lang noch
verkleben und dann warten wir und dann
bröselt es auch langsam weg war wie
pacman habe ich zwar nicht getestet aber
ich glaube es verkauf es gibt auch die
idee die zerfallen auch in ihre
einzelteile
und das bleibt auch noch ein bisschen
länger kleben und bei kiefern klappt das
auch nur da muss jetzt vorsichtig sein
ständiges explodiert und dabei die ganz
kaputt gemacht und der kritik dann hier
auch in seinen einzelteilen rum
das funktioniert nicht bei allen mods
bei allen mops ich verwechsle mods mit
mops zb wenn ich eine spinne haben oder
so und die schlage dann das funktioniert
zum beispiel nicht oder wenn ich jetzt
zu schwein hat zum beispiel funktioniert
das auch nicht oder ein williger damit
todesschütze dann funktioniert das auch
nicht also der mord ist auf jeden fall
noch ein wenig ausbaufähig aber für den
moment auf dem festmahl ganz cool ich
zeig euch noch mal kurz das beispiel von
zb einem zombie dafür mit einem kurzen
weiterflug und so weiter
da also sieht schon echt geil aus und ja
wenn man auf jeden fall irgendwelche
hoch auf filme oder so drehen da im mai
kräftig lassen ich habe keine filme
drehen wollte und da sind die monster
dennoch transaktion entsteht wenn ich zb
einmal so ein monster höhere und dann
bricht das mandat ist auf jeden fall
schon ganz cool für filmemacher oder
allgemein wenn ihr eurem ein
kräftemessen aufbessern wollte und dann
will ich sagen was das mit dieser mod
video und zwar habt ihr mit sicherheit
schon mitbekommen dass ich das dieses
mal nicht in dem jetzt das war knapp
also hat mitbekommen dass ich das dieses
mal nicht in dem im ort vorstellung
traum gemacht habt also nicht in dem
raum in diesem raum dort sondern hier in
dem raum in dem monster raum weil ich
wollte einfach nicht dort hinten
riskieren creeper einzusetzen und das
ihr dasein als in luft sprengen was ich
hier mal so aufgebaut habe daher habe
ich halt das heute mal in meinen augen
macht also schaffen wir eventuell 505 50
likes für diesen extrem coolen motto
dieses extrem coole features langes
stück gedauert hat hinzuzufügen
von der funktion her zwar nicht so viel
beinhaltet aber auf jeden fall schon
cool ist bei und ein paar sachen
hinzufügt ich stelle mich jetzt auf den
steve kopf und würde sagen wenn wir das
schaffen das wäre echt extrem geil
und dann will ich sagen sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal meine lieben freunde